can I ask you a question what do you
think of Kevin's suit because he
obviously thinks that like he you know
he killed it tonight
he looked like Bagger Vance that's what
I said my dad has a suit like that yeah
he looked like a old orthopedic doctor
that's what I was trying to explain to
him and he didn't get it and I was
trying to tell them he's classic you got
a classic look today the vintage archaic
look I want to ask you Pat Williams came
over and he apologized and you took the
high road you really went Michelle Obama
on him and didn't go back at him because
you could have been like Katt yeah I
could have said a lot of things but it's
for what why why waste the energy I got
I got a lot of other things if I got a
movie coming out three movies coming up
I got a lot of work and I'm doing get
ready should another movie I'm producing
right but it was beautiful though that
evening it was nice of him yes it was
very kind of did you notice you were
holding your Emmy while he was doing
that and did you see Elizabeth Mars in
the background who's also starring in a
movie with me cause the kitchen is
coming out next year okay so we squash
that that's enough of that all right
what does it mean to be in Kevin's movie
is first one for heartbeat productions
which is a big deal but it means the
world to me I mean to be able to work
with this man who I've known for years
and to be in his first project that is
his project is an honor and a privilege
you're starting to be kind of a
situation on carpet you were the star of
the Oscars you're the star of the Emmys
you know it's like people are waiting
for you now that whole Oscar what's she
wearing what's she gonna what is that
like when you hit the carpet now of
these award shows I mean I didn't know
people were waiting for me they're
waiting for you I have no idea I'm just
there to have a good time and enjoy the
experience if they're waiting for you
though well that's nice the dance away
from me that's polite thank you guys for
waiting tell me about what you're
wearing tonight that's the night I'm
wearing a dress that has stripes in
black and white
brought by check the thing okay hold on
I'll check your tag hold on and I'm not
being nasty
Christina's Oh Christian Siriano I
didn't want to say it out loud I want
you to say for me Christmas period he
makes great stuff yes he does and it
fits perfectly he makes it for real body
to make this pose for robot exactly what
he does and y'all are opening up the
urban World Festival how cool is that
this is amazing you know to be able to
be a part of the urban World Festival
means that we are doing fantastic
everything for the world I love you too
[Music]